all right hello everyone it's great to
be back here at e3 this year with
Microsoft and Xbox so last year we gave
you a glimpse of a New York City on the
brink of collapse
paralyzed by a devastating and deadly
virus which was released on Black Friday
and this year we want to take you even
deeper into our world so let's join a
group of division agents as we navigate
through a dangerous part of the city on
our way to establishing a critical
foothold in an area which has been
overrun by hostile factions snow is
falling down just a little bit the world
so quiet and still saddles out there
flying around on it
okay I know where we are I'm setting the
waypoint to the base check your map
Donald hi looks like it's pretty close
all right follow me this way looks clear
getting a reading over here
this must've been the last train out
looks like everybody panicked
okay where's Bronson son of another
invite this must be where they were
talking about watch your step
there you are hey guys I brought Chris
hey Chris hey scoping out the area bed
okay we're about to unlock my bass it's
up here on the right
all right so what do we got here leaves
by the base and behind the truck market
of up Rena okay let's take these guys
out first as quietly as possible
all right I'm Tessa and pulls up all
right Ryan let's change up our skills
I'll pull aggro from the left here you
guys good to go all good yeah ready all
right here we go
gunshot got incoming
all right let's go okay come from the
right bank up
watch out without their holy crap here
they are
there's loads of them take your shot
you mark some of these guys go trouble I
can't move on pin gotta hit him
Christmas all you dude yeah I'm on it
light him up Oh God look out let's go go
go get down I'm pushing for to push for
wait oh there's a guy right behind me
all right you're fine yep okay doc - hit
him hit him
get this guy on the left
okay go go we got to move up forward
last one keep the pressure on
that is the last one good game guys okay
that's good
welcome guys so this is the base of
operations
and I'm thinking
starting a medical online for